hello welcome back to YouTube
we are you - this is YouTube right now
if you go to youtube.com this is this
all the cat videos [ __ ] gone
it's just lost talking about video games
jasiek Nintendo 80 of my friends it's
going on good good to have you I like
you to pin here yeah you can get it
we're actually showing off a Star Fox
zero downstairs so if you kind of go in
life you happen to get one of those like
sitting the cockpit and flying our wing
yeah you get one of these guys what I
andre GameXplain Justin's here I'm here
it's like white where are our pins where
the Triforce here's the three of us we
could be playing the game where I pit
where our pens up in here yeah you know
it's supposed to be a team I mean I can
dub you guys like the you know the
honorary Triforce temporary treasure air
aiming for you to get me in GameSpot
I'll I'll double you guys the official
unofficial Triforce so Justin's the red
one obviously you go for blue and I
guess I'm Irish so yes that's really
good and you know it's funny those
colors do correspond to the character
perfect yeah yeah it's right on and try
first here's a tell us all about it for
the photo no oh my gosh three player
what's up why are there so many links
what's going on they are they are all
together and it's it's in three player
cooperative you know kind of top-down
Zelda game and there's it's a lot about
cooperation I don't you have some member
for swords you guys like for swords
because it's very similar to that where
you have to work together not too much
picking up and throwing people off it's
more about you know you share the life
bar right you have to work together to
pick each other up in this new thing
called the totem mechanic where you can
pick one character up and then you're
you're you know you're so you have a
stack of two lengths high and you can
pick someone else up and then put them
at top so there's like three altogether
and then there are some obstacles and
things you have to do at that level so
in once I got the gameplay I think we
have it up yeah we got it right there
cooperation not a competition that's
right yes it all have to cooperate so
what's your esteem right now was a place
called a snowball ravine this is one of
the newer levels that we actually do not
have for playing those you're already
getting it little you know will preview
it one of the newer levels and so what
they're doing is that's very good so
whoever's blue who is very smart and
this is live that there are some people
in the back playing this right
absolutely like hopefully they can hear
my voice and we're gonna be good
and you can chip as you saw at the
bottom if you touch on the bottom screen
because all emoticons it's like over
here item or throw if you tap them don't
put these little pictures up and you can
you know you get your mom but like
pom-poms or give somebody a thumbs up oh
yes and that's one of the new things
about the boomerang so as you go to the
level there are a certain powerup so two
people having fire gloves as you can
throw it there you can throw the
fireball and it makes a little time that
something somewhat kids'll your time
window that suppose a fireball in town
and they're supposed to go over there
and find hearts they can find rubies and
they're all supposed to stand on that
Triforce my people gonna go and get some
snowballs
close all right you're so good you're so
good so I'm just gonna step on the
Triforce it's alright Justin I know
you're a big fan of the link between
worlds I just sort of taken that process
of style on it and you excited about
this I know you play all these games but
Buda you are you looking forward to
playing it with with somebody else
cooperate
I definitely of course the art style the
way the game looks is the law is very
similar to for swords but there's only
three players so I guess it wouldn't
have made sense to call before story but
I mean any of these older games where
you get to just pair up with people
where you can to partner with friends
whether they're around you or not like
it's such a fun Felda experience like
getting to share solving these puzzles
and how to get around things and and I
think sharing love the life bar adds an
element of risk that you wouldn't get up
everybody you could be charged to one
another and push them off cliffs or
knock them out like I think it actually
has a little bit of fun that you have to
look out for one another yeah and you
know it's funny that whole looking up
for one another um you know at work I
would hear I would hear people and if
somebody screams or like no no no way we
do this do that it's like everyone knows
immediately that they are playing this
game yeah it's like there's there's
there's no doubt but ooh this is a
little challenging puzzle over here so
remember how I told that there's
actually like about team working about
cooperating
they're gonna have to stack up three
people hi oh right job Marin
and whoever whoever that was yes that's
okay there we go
they got it the person on the top
believe me I'll throw it Oh close show
let's hunt it a few more times and oh
come to mention it I don't know if you
noticed but if you take a look at that
like a look at Maurin and you thinking
like a holly the ones that are like a
blue and blue and red they're actually
sliding around a little bit okay because
they're walking on ice now one of the
new power-ups is called the Kochi parka
so whoever Thank You marina has the cozy
parka and they will not actually slide
around they're also they're also
protected from really dark spots or like
super cold I'm not gonna get hurt yeah
there we go
well done so can you share at those
inventory items can you say okay you
have it for now or do you sort of you
get stuck with your inventory items
whole thing and then oh you're wearing
the things that you better go do the
thing yes so it kind of watch two
different ways so before you set up the
you know the game everyone can choose a
kind of clothing option so the clothing
option kind of may give you like
multiple arrows and they could you know
you'll be able to produce bombs or
larger bombs and when diplomas like the
cozy parka which you know don't slide on
ice but once you get to the level
there's certain level specific things
that you're going to need let's say for
example in thermal regime you have to
kind of like fireball gloves or you know
that can that can spit fireball but
there's only one boomerang person so the
person with the boomerang has to be the
one to bring the other people over all
right you have to kind of strategize
beforehand talk it out and see who wants
to do what I always feel like in these
games there's always somebody who's like
has to be like the boss like somebody
who's like alright I'm in control like
I'm gonna take charge of this team like
we're gonna go over here like Andre on
GameXplain you you know so much about
these games you're very skillful at them
when you're playing a game like this you
like instantly just go okay this is how
we're doing it you go there you go there
you go there yeah I mean you don't think
I like a game plan right I mean think
it's like I love cooperative games but
conversely I'm not about to I'm not I'm
not much of a team player myself no it's
kind of trolling everyone else so I'll
tell them what to do by might mess with
them the cross
- so pull them off a few clubs see what
happened maybe a shared life bar well
sort of it kind of got temperate all
right so pushing myself then for it so
yeah
digital how I difficult do the levels
guys because obviously what a game like
this you have to be very careful not to
because you you can frustrate if you
frustrate anyone playing a game they'll
want to stop playing it and when there's
three people playing the chances of
prostrating somebody are so much higher
so like do you read what's like the
learning curve on this just get pretty
simple does it get hard to the end you
know what I think there's gonna be
something in it for everyone you know
this game is really cleverly designed
where you know the button cert they're
not very there every difficult of all I
mean you have you know one button that
you can run you can swing a sword you
have your special move and you press a
button to pick up four totem or cost
something so that's pretty simple if
you're just starting out with herself
your first this is your first tell
metell it's a good one
however if you are kind of more they
looking for the cheaper stuff I mean
just have to notice there's really small
things like instead of snowballs they'll
be rocks coming in so you have to know
all can't burn those with your fireball
with other the snowballs you could and
so or like these areas like sometimes
people come and pick up on it right that
was nice if they don't pick up on it
there's a lot more things to explore
depending on however look at that see so
you know okay you know exploring these
other things and the worlds become
bigger as she continued to explore so if
you just keep your eye out for things
just a lot of depth a lot of things that
will surprises hidden for people that
are really you know poor like just fans
for the franchise yeah and to tell the
games I guess the emoticons really
helped people communicate in a
simplistic way consuming most people
gonna play this is gonna be playing
online not in like their local
well I wouldn't know I wouldn't know
people get together and play cuz you can
do things see absolutely like um my
personal favorite thing is getting to
sit next some one like you Danny and I
would love to play with you guys just
because that interaction that you have
between people when you see someone else
smile like that will flight nod and
you're smiling because maybe Andres
asking about the side of a hook if you
wanted to throw me down you can tell
them they suck to their face well then
there's less possibility of that because
you're kind of telling it to their face
like you're kind of accountable okay
Justin feed more jockey right you can't
you're about probably about how they
play zeldo right you can tell what kind
person they are oh my god completely and
in this one you know that teamwork it's
gonna be really key so I think it's
incredibly fun to watch how people kind
of solve problems and solve you know how
they get around it
like if someone flow if they're all
lowing humping I'd like to have two
hearts how careful are they are they
helping each other they don't the best
way to do is just talk it out you know
for the folks who are watching here do
you guys have a playable at all anywhere
on the floor here you know what we do
for the people in the audience if you
want to play you know legend sell the
Triforce heroes this game is actually in
one of our gaming lounge it's on the
second floor you'll see like two SS a
series of escalators I go up and then
the third floor we have Star Fox here on
the second floor there is some Triforce
heroes if I keep your elbows if flash
and a ton of other games were showing
here
oh thanks cut to the boss oh here we go
oh this is gonna be interesting so this
particular boss is really tricky because
he'll start blowing that ice that kind
of ice breath and running around the
church can see if he has some weak
points on his arms on his back and you
know people on the fire ball although
they're in a really good job I kind of
staying away what's really cool is I
don't know if the first of the car come
no it's perfect see the cozy Parker
person is trying to move pull aggro yeah
yeah that's great that's actually
exactly what you wanted genius is back
there that's right good job ladies
before yeah I'll take you to your legal
and no thumbs-up
he's almost gone and what's interesting
is if you have the boomerang you know
you don't have a fire ball but the fire
something they didn't hurt him what you
should do is put yourself she doesn't
blame ya yeah you can put yourself
behind with those torches throw them on
rank if the light on fire hits the enemy
and then come back oh poor dude not yet
we're on the face - they better get some
help okay here we go
likes five different versions and these
three right yeah he's just like a
decapitated head man he's just walking
around jumping he's angry how many
different worlds are there how many bit
different bosses like I will say is
there some fun so if you are I wonder if
you bake yeah I know so I'll say there's
a lot it's a considerable amount of fun
especially because when you have the
ability to select those different
outfits and you have like different ways
to approach the level depending on your
abilities it's also a lot of fun to go
into the ones you already know and go
wait a minute what happens in my hands
instead yeah like you know trying to
approach a level this way so that's
really really different please have a
fresh you know look at the Zelda info
wait are you unlocking more items later
in the games and then you can kind of
replay in older levels yes I think
there's a penny more you know the more
you play the more assets again
they almost haven't done on phase two
yeah they're almost like they're we can
do it guys
he's flashing you got a corner just like
couple more hits maybe one or two when
the Iceman flashes that means he's
almost dead oh okay gets dark
I think this was it yeah a round of
applause the guys in the back up
everyone hit Edie awesome so Triforce
heroes for the folks that aren't here we
want to pick it up at Windsor that what
sit out this holiday this holiday this
on it is that is that as specific as you
can get I can get more specific but I
can't actually member top my head
remember
JC thanks so much for taking someone
you'd appreciate it any idea for
everyone who's here they can play it on
the second floor second door thanks so
much for coming on dude appreciate it
what you gonna do for the rest of your
day here at PAX I'll play play a lot
more games I think yeah come on look
there's a lot out there yeah a lot of
lines to get in enjoy I just um what
about yourself
anything on the on the news front at the
moment oh there's a lot more games to
see we're doing a lot of previews a lot
of interviews and you know going over to
games.com we were able to read about
everything else that you might not have
gotten to try out here on the show floor
cool and we got much more video stuff
coming up here and live from pax prime
so if you're watching on gaming that
YouTube for GameSpot make sure you hit
that little Add button and you can get
all the latest news from us throughout
the day Randy Pitchford is gonna be up
in a little while but in a little time I
got to talk to a guy I haven't talked to
a couple of years and mr.
CaptainSparklez is up next so stay tuned